what's up reject nation happy
international
women's day to our 85 percent male
demographic so to the 15
female demographic i hope half of you
are watching
get that seven and a half percent that's
right
this is just for you guys just gents
girls yeah girls be respectful girl
ladies chicks what
are we talking about we should have
slept
this weekend justice league snyder cut
wonder woman
trailer wonder woman is my favorite of
the dceu
films and zack snyder he's the one
who discovered her and watching her back
in the bvs ultimate cut
like damn zachary did
good she is so badass and that
is pretty legit i am so excited to see
what she does
i hope all 15 of the demographic is
watching
[Music]
oh that's messed up man
i watch your island burn oh what a dick
thing to say
yeah man it was a way back darkseid's a
mean guy
i think that was steppenwolf stephen
wolf's a mean guy too
steppenwolf or dark side sometimes
they're getting their voices confused
now and these trainers
clarify i feel like that'd be
steppenwolf because he literally took
that island down
yeah you're probably right and my nerd
cred is not showing
um i'm talking about yeah earlier in the
movie you know maybe he's saying that
before he turns around
[Music]
something is coming back to the dark
ages
suave she looks
we have no problems
i love that he does look a lot better
so i have no fear we have no friends
beautiful absolutely beautiful yeah
remember the time when
people thought she couldn't pull it off
yes i do
remember that time i don't know she can
and now look at her today
can't imagine anyone else in the role
right now you know what i've been loving
about all these teases too
especially is yes zack snyder's versions
of these characters
are much darker and uh i love that i
love that if
you guys have been following this
channel just in the last couple weeks
you'll see that i'm constantly taking
time out of the video just to rave about
that bvs ultimate edition all right
take a drink each time constantly doing
it it is so damn good if you guys
haven't seen it watch it all right
um there's other videos where i've gone
more into depth about things that i love
about it
what i've been loving about these teases
especially even with here you got wonder
woman
who's standing upon is this for sure
themyscira
i guess that's where my mind goes
although it certainly looks like a just
a greek ruin too
you know what this is the only reason
like i i i've undergone on the
impression this sequence is specifically
from
them is hero yeah right that's where all
of us have believed and then you go down
to the temple
it's this this is rails it's the guard
rails these modern day garger hills here
only thing that throws me off like is
there a parking lot just behind this
blown out wall
but i'm pretty sure it's in the mosquiro
where she goes back and she learns the
whole history
of the wars and dark side and all that
as we've all
thought that's how it's supposed to go
down right regardless there's a role
with the punches that this is that
muscular what's cool about this is that
she's looking upon
like kind of this isolated dark
desolate mood right that's how it's kind
of been for all these characters
they're all lonely they're all in this
really dark place
even for wonder woman this symbol of
hope as she's looking upon this uh
the the sea you know this like knowing
that there's something
dangerous and dark and evil coming what
brings them hope especially by the end
of these trailers is the unity of them
coming together
that is somber as things are as desolate
as the situation is
even in the line that she has here is
like we have to fight together we do
this together
i don't know how bad the destruction
will be of themschira
at the beginning of this movie uh when
steppenwolf does come to
retrieve the mother box like yes that is
in the justice league version
but it was dialed down way down yeah but
when you look here it looks
pretty much like oh they don't mess some
[ __ ] up you know like darks
uh steppenwolf has stepped in and really
destroyed some stuff so when they say
like i watched your island burn i think
that is steppenwolf
saying that i don't think it's in in in
um
discussion with the previous war cause
i'm like what much what kind of threat
would that be if
like yeah i watched your eye on them
burn but it got rebuilt
so it has to be a reference to earlier
in the movie this makes it that much
more
personal for her like as i was talking
about in the flash trailer same thing
here for diana this is something that
feels like it got
lost in the justice league version of
this character at the beginning of the
movie her
homeland is [ __ ] uh invaded
and a lot of her people are murdered
it's a real
harrowing dark feeling and as you see
here in this trailer
that is what's gonna make this journey
personal for all them i think what zack
snyder is gonna do such a great job on
is even though it's an ensemble piece
this mission
of defeating steppenwolf is going to
feel like a very personal journey
for all of them and not just heroes have
to come together and fight a big bad you
know what i mean
and i think that's what's so well
demonstrated just even even in these
like little
little tidbits i'm surprisingly getting
a lot more from these little tidbits
than i expected well yeah and the sun in
the background too i don't know gave me
the impression of either a sunrise or a
sunset and so you have these characters
at the outset who are so disparate from
one another and who are grieving for
something you know going into some sort
of dark night of the soul and then that
sunrise can be
them teaming up and whatnot so even
though you have all the teasers i've
seen
this is the most sort of still of them i
also appreciate that that's kind of
hinting to me that this movie will also
have some dynamics you know the
dinos we're going to die in this movie
for sure
i was talking about dying ah
dynamics there we go ah
we should have slept this week because
it's pulling me more into the moods of
the characters as well as all the cool
[ __ ] that we're
looking forward to seeing and all that
stuff so yeah like i thought this had a
lot of mood to it
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below happy international women's
day
to you all happy women's month
women's month it's women's history month
oh that's right
and it's women's day so it's like extra
women today
i wish i knew a single thing about women
we should learn about women
comment below if you've ever seen a
woman they don't usually let me look at
them
that's probably for the best me neither
i've read about them in stories but only
descriptions
never with any illustrations or
photographic
additionally uh yeah i have like a
raiders of the lost ark situation my
face just melts
yeah femininity is the ark of the
covenant and to gaze upon it is to have
your soul transcend in a way that your
body just couldn't ever
hope to withstand all right guys was
that hippolyta at the beginning
tell me all the voices that you heard in
this trailer subscribe
click that notification bell hit likety
like buttons
hey last but not least
who's the wonder woman of this page who
do you think i'm going to say josh i
think you're going to say
our favorite online critic and super
badass mom
ms rosara john and i did not
even we didn't even look up coordinating
we didn't even
look up your name we didn't even pull up
this shout out list
we scheme we just knew that is the truth
that is actually the truth
actually because you have a very
specific role here you are the matriarch
that's all right society that's right
real rejects is a matriarchal system you
are the themischiro you are you're a big
island are a big
lush islander you're the promise wrong
sexy woman is where you are
yes and you don't cheat that's the other
thing is uh you you value
hard work reference to orson welles 1984
and 84. definitely orson welles
gosh do good stuff all the time
right